heroes it's an old-fashioned notion a  missionary from genius ensuring freedom  around the globe symbol to the nation  a hero to the world the beautiful  shining out across the Stars  I look around the bus you know I see a  bunch of a-holes possibility you think  you know how the world works  the world  is changing  we need  heroes  I'll bury strength  [Music]  invites challenge  Challenge insights contract  culture  Brie's catastrophe  the thing isn't beautiful because it  lasts  [Music]  we're in the anger  before we're done  [Music]  we still have one promise to keep  you can't protect the Earth it can be  damn sure we'll avenge it  whatever it takes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you